[Applaudissements]
sa seule indique de la rédac après y
aura des questions du public ouvre à
dire toute la vérité écoute moi écoutez
moi bien chez j ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai pas autant
franchement je sais pas pour vous mais
j'ai pleuré j'ai des potes qui
m'envoient notamment à mon amour mon ami
christian l'habite de narbonne qui me
dit je pleure de rire la pub merci à la
cpi de recourir quel faux est énorme
alors l'indiquent de l'aréna qui est
haussier sur les équipes ici là on passe
au sérieux ses rides puisque j'ai des
dossiers sur tous les chroniqueurs et
même de personnes en particulier vous
allez voir dans un instant qu'est ce qui
s'est passé lundi lundi syrie nous
étions le 12 octobre et le 12 octobre
restera marqué 2 octobre oui nous le 12
octobre
cette date restera gravé dans l'histoire
de thé pmp cyril une date d'anthologie
c'est quoi la preuve vous en avais même
parlé en début d'émission
ça se résume en quatre lettres p o j'ai
est passé exactement
parti seul gros seins benjamin castaldi
exactement et là on assiste est vraiment
à la naissance de quelque chose de très
grand regardez même mme isabelle ne s'en
est toujours pas remise depuis lundi
c'est la naissance de boxe
[Musique]
elle est revenue votre mariage c'est là
où tu t'es pas bien je sais les miss
faut parler comme ça la plage torse nu
ce n'est pas bon pour elles n'ont cessé
castaldi
lundi 12 octobre 2020 nous avons assisté
en direct à la naissance de forbes
que signifie cet acronyme que veut dire
syrie mona vous saurez dans quelques
secondes le temps plein
oui mario paquet des piercings et
tatouages à plein kelly il va dire où
s'ébattent ce que vous aviez une belle
voiture jusqu'à la lie piercings
tatouages bolat l'érosion des
compléments historiquement quand il faut
les bannir ans et de cassard fois sur
les femmes bien sûr que les hommes sont
complexés on n'a pas la chance de faire
tous à 99
[Applaudissements]
what was match et tu fais pas le trou
alors s'il vous plaît pas de dons lui
pas devant lui il va nous faire une suti
marceau le prochain festival de cannes
oui il a chéri
[Applaudissements]
l'adhésion de benjamin j'ai bien écouté
monde vous appelle vous êtes magnifique
vous avez une poitrine et au bras vous
voulez de la lettre c'est bon c'est vrai
que ça fait quelques émissions qu'on
revoie un peu plus maxime gainey bah ça
y est il est reparti ouais bah oui
maxime est très bon lundi qu'après votre
choix attirer les mais vous allez
comprendre pourquoi on parle de maxime
ce qui est un problème avec maxime gagné
6 bat aucun camarades ne veut jouer le
jeu avec maxime gagnon le pauvre maxime
et oui aucun chroniqueur ne veut
s'amuser avec maxime gainey maxime est
même considéré comme un ringard par son
chroniqueur away et sa land x ne peut
pas accepter dont vous êtes le moins
ringard quoique 1 à des images
quoique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
shop boys band store
[Musique]
comment
est ce que quelqu'un me semble lancée
avec maxime koenig banon mais regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'autre quel regard par des musulmans ah
la la
que la paix soit avec moi
[Musique]
je
à
j'aime d'ajouter que les choses avec moi
sur quels lots ne revient pas le regarde
pas le regarde pas non plus
[Musique]
je vais essayer avec qui sort
aujourd'hui va bien il n'y a plus un peu
de la gueule
justement c'est une question pour vous
du public
est ce que tu t'es senti menacé maxime
par l'arrivée de clément garin et sasha
une base dans l'équipe up du tout moi
j'ai un contrat à l'année avec vous donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
eu tout bon
oui si ça va ça vient on vient en par le
passé ça va très bien bon on est content
que vous voyez la rue moussy s'écoule
pas très bien mon maxi chose oui avant
de diffuser le prochain magnéto cyril
j'ai une question à poser à la table des
chroniqueurs ne touchent pas en poste
ici présents ce soir qui selon vous est
le chroniqueur le plus bas tard de
l'histoire de touche pas à mon poste
c'est de votre séjour entre eux jean
michel lemaire et et majorettes et agile
qui est sympa mais bon voilà de quoi sa
passion j'ai l'impression quand même que
ça joue plutôt entre jean michel et jean
michel vous allez voir c'est le
chroniqueur il ne s'entend avec personne
il ya des faillites avec tout le monde
c'est jean-michel le tarbes à regarder
[Musique]
c'est un grand jour au jour c'est
l'anniversaire de la petite
la sympathie je pouvais être intéressé
par la chanteuse est restée à ses côtés
elle nous a jamais faber a été si
souvent à se relever
c'est doublement du
c'est angie se consoler pardonnez moi
mais c'est bluffant en l'honneur de
bertrand kamel quelques temps après la
cérémonie d'enterrement
ils étaient tous là autour de la famille
donc c'était bravo bravo à eux s'étaient
pas fan du tout des affiches dans cette
aventure et des infographies
meriem
jean pascal il est bon ton chez les
motos shakespeare
passé par ailleurs
c'est un peu comme vous mais jamais en
moi demain c'était la première fois
qu'on pense que d'individus
[Applaudissements]
des textes de tallinn à jean-michel
justement une question beaucoup du
public qu'elle chroniqueuse
choisirais-tu pour la vie pour la nuit
et celle avec qui tu dis jamais de la
vie de choisir plaint de quoi en faire
de même cette dette pour la vie je
dirais valérie bénaïm ah ouais ouais
pour une nuit géraldine maillet pour une
heure et libido velits et jamais de la
vie
by sabelt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
justement il ya une question pourquoi
clément parce qu'on parlait clément et
maxime y un instant donné nous le top 3
et le feu 3 top 3 et floch 3 des
chroniqueurs actuellement dans tpm pays
un avis personnel des coupures très
importantes 3 je m'entends très bien
avec isabelle je m'entends très bien
avec raimon et j'ai envie de dire maxime
aussi parce que tout le monde nous
prêtent une rivalité qui n'existent pas
vraiment qui va revenir kelly aussi
kelly qui est un petit peu souffrons
irez-vous qui voit là avec était fatigué
aussi qu'ils résident semaine prochaine
et chats et flops 3 franchement tout le
monde est sympa donc j'ai pas envie de
fracasser leurs clopes un flop
jean-michel ouimet a tendu la main à
l'est oui c'est lille pour terminer est
ce que vous savez quel est mon rêve mon
plus grand rêve cyril bien sûr c'est de
pécho géraldine maillet alors y avait ça
mais c'est raté
donc du coup je me suis concentré sur
mon vrai rêve c'est de devenir peut-être
un jour comme vous un grand animateur
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait cyril j'ai pris
une émission entière ne touche pas à mon
poste mais en bon indique bien sûr et je
vous ai observé j'ai regardé et j'ai
compris à a
vous avez aimé le maire j'ai compris
celles j'ai compris en regardant votre
façon de faire votre façon d'animer vous
sentez les émissions vous vivez les
émissions j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle un
focus baba à regarder si on exclut oui
alors il ya eu une polémique dans ce vol
ce samedi soir à cause du commis de 10,9
suite à une remarque de florent pagny
sur le plateau regarde c'était fait
exprès
je crois que c'est pesé est ce que tu
crois que c'est pour buzz est très bien
selon un panier c'est une goutte il dit
la vérité ce que les gens tuent la
vérité il est pas chez lui à vélo tu
n'es pas chez lui et en vrai ce ne sera
pas comme ça et ben il dit la mère si la
brune
je rappelle que les brunes comptent pas
pour des prunes je serai que ce n'est
pas inné quand même une finale ou rabais
ils ont mis les gros moyens y avait des
danseuses et tout ça allait dans ce sens
il avait qu'à pas dire c'est une blague
faut quand même rappeler le principe des
all blacks c'est que ça doit être drôle
là il a rien de drôle si on me demandait
si chacun fait ça c'est sûr c'est vrai
que les escalades de lorraine jean
michel maire donc il se vante sur le
service public où elles emballent
heureux ça va chercher loin ça la jeune
femme elle n'a pas fait du porno faut
arrêter quand même envoyé c'est une
jolie photo de charme de sourds au goût
certain et des paroles d'évangile
d'accord mais il a dit van chi des vents
gilles verdez et lorsque je suis seul
dans la rue et que la rue n'est pas
bondée d'autres jeunes à choquer je
comprends tiffany également je vous
comprends je vous ai compris
[Applaudissements]
m'attendais à pire des régimes ou si
c'est cela